before Tesla moved in back in October
2010 this Factory in freeboard was the
home of new me which was a joint venture
between General Motors and Toyota it was
at the time where two industry was
struggling and we were able to buy this
back to him for relatively low purchase
price and we decided to essentially
refurbish the factory from scratch
I was based at SpaceX making rockets and
the SpaceX Factory it was really super
clean super light super open and so when
we were able to acquire the Tesla
factory we said okay we need to make it
similar to SpaceX we're gonna paint the
ceilings white the columns white I'm
gonna make it bright while we have the
ability to add skylights we're going to
have the light from the sky you know and
the psychology of that is if you want
quality you need people to feel at ease
you need people to feel like this is a
quality place here I need to make a
quality product we constantly try to
improve process efficiency we're
utilizing automation to the fullest we
have about 160 robots the latest
technology you can find on the planet
that are able to do very diverse tasks
robots are extremely good at
repeatability accuracy of motion but
humans are more intelligent than robots
therefore we need to use humans where
there's a lot of value for that
intelligence here we are in Silicon
Valley right so you have wonderful
universities you know Stanford Berkeley
UC Davis you name it too we have a lot
of talent so we want to take full
advantage of having highly educated
people help us improve the automation
you
what is unique about building the Model
S's electric vehicle is a lot of the
components are actually very different
like the drive units the battery pack
the battery modules a lot of those
components do not exist anywhere else so
we need to do a lot more than any other
factories that I have been add in terms
of sub processes inside the factory we
do about 95% of our time cleaning house
we do a lot of the machining in-house we
do some coding in-house we do painting
in-house we do the center display
in-house so the level of integration is
very very high and because everything is
here it speeds things up greatly and
that speed has a lot of intrinsic value
in terms of innovation adaptability
flexibility all of them in the future we
have a lot of opportunity to grow and
bring more this product to the market
and so you know huge potential here